we favor don't go disappearing today you
come straight back from the bank right
eat your eggs are gonna be like ice you
open yeah well
why are you following me are you looking
for a friend to hang with I'll be your
friend if that's what you're looking for
hiya Leo Leo this is my friend hey Leo
you get any new Hanks knowing you'll be
the first to know Vic what's your name
again I don't know what do you want it
to be you're weird
pretty weird yourself it's a good thing
[Music]
what do you know about this girl
where's she from what's the name so you
don't use the name what you tryna let
you don't use the name she's the gal who
invented kissing like the Hank Snow song
so long you know Jimmy and Victor long
time says you're not for money compared
to mid treble get it out of your head
that I'm just gonna keep taking care of
you for the rest of your life I'm your
brother what is your name so what
happened here different I know it was an
act of God even leave my little brother
alone
wasn't enough that you're the handsome
brother that you are the smart brother
okay
only the mediocre always at their best
and ain't us
[Music]
you
[Music]
you